[Music]
this all started you guys are best
friends from high school he went to high
school on Staten Island at all-boys
Catholic High School nobody we get a
very anti-catholic rap
mostly they come here to taunt me yeah
so why did you go to an all Catholic
school Staten Island oh boy all and and
so this is what comes from a school like
this is the result we had nothing to
distract us from pranking each other
yeah you know so you just rate you see
you literally grew up pranking you learn
a lot about the Lord and a lot about
dudes yep right and then we had an
experience very similar to Matt LeBlanc
actually I remember telling Matt
LeBlanc's mom that I want to become a
comedian yeah she said what do you know
about that and I said you know nothing
matt LeBlanc mom Mercedes here's a used
Prius now you guys you compete in
hidden-camera scenarios and the loser is
punished yeah okay you know you have
very strict rules on sort of the golden
rules for pranks is that correct well we
we're a comedy troupe called the
tenderloins we created it after high
school and years ago we created a pact
and the pact was this you cannot say no
to a punishment when we came up with the
idea for the show you can't say no to a
punishment and you must do whatever
you're told no matter what so the
punishments have gotten really
outrageous the season yeah because we
can't say no yeah well we also don't
know what it is the person being
punished doesn't know what it is the
other guys conspire against them so when
we show up that's why we made the pact
because a lot of times we know we'll
just like oh my god and it's like you
have to do it you can't even if it's
your worst fear if these guys tell you
to do something you have to do it you
got to do that's the rule man okay what
are your favorite pranks so far that
you've you've done just off the top of
your head you know one of my favorites
is we do a challenge called leading the
blind and I brought the sunglasses you
can see what they look like they look
like normal sunglasses but actually
they're blacked out on the inside around
with you what are you doing why do you
have no
it has them this ring is ready to go so
the sunglasses are blacked out on the
inside so you can't see out of them at
all right so the challenge is this we've
got to put them on and the guys are
telling us where we have to walk to and
what we have to say you don't know who
you're saying it to though so we were in
the park and they say Murr put the
sunglasses on walk ten steps you're left
three steps you're right turn around now
say this come here
remember I can't see who I'm singing
remember yes you can't see outside of
them so and they take the sunglasses off
and I'm going to and I'm standing
outside of a children's playground
Coenen that's a very risky joke is
legally he's not allowed within 50 feet
of we have this is I think this is a
clip of punishment this is was this one
of the worst ones we're gonna show a
clip right now which I can't remember
who is it had to be the nude mob yeah
the nude Matas this was naked that makes
it worse okay we have a clip here
anything we need to know to set this up
what do we well he lost the episode
James and we told me he had to go into a
classroom to teach an art class but
hidden what he didn't know was it was a
nude model art class and he was the
model okay and when you heard that this
was going to happen how upset were you
well I have the kind of body that
shouldn't be naked in the shower right
so I was upset you're upset let's take a
look at this this clip from Impractical
Jokers
it's just Murr standing at a room of
silent people holding his own balls
alright so what we're gonna do is gonna
give you a couple poses buddy okay ready
I want you to give them a Heisman Trophy
[Laughter]
[Music]
give me an Egyptian go be cutting his
hands off his baggage what Murray
doesn't know is that his stage routine
[Applause]